j'ai pas des résultats définitifs j'ai
des résultats qui seront quasi définitif
ou qui sont quasi-définitifs et donc la
liste que j'ai eu l'honneur de mener
dijon c'est capitale emporte 45% des
voix et la liste la liste d'emmanuel
bichot 34 et celle des de madame mode 21
voilà voilà donc je suis très heureux de
cette victoire de pascal un contexte
très particulier pour moi
d'abord c'est la quatrième fois que je
suis réélu par les dijonnais
ensuite parce que j'ai eus faire face
j'ai eu à faire face à une campagne
absolument ignominieuse de du candidat
de droite avec le soutien du principal
syndicat de police qui a été jusqu'à
raconter des choses qui sont absolument
fausses donc il a bien ratissé toute
l'extrême droite
il arrive à 34 et la figure du conseil
municipal la figure demain du conseil
municipal sera la même que celle qui est
sortante six élus verts 43 élus de la
majorité ps et modem et une dizaine
d'élus de droite de droite et on
pourrait presque dire de droite et
l'extrême droite enfin ses sens commun
c'est cc on voit bien c'est tous ceux
qui refusent la vie telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
c'est ce foyer réactionnaire qu'on peut
pas réduire dans cette ville et qui pèse
à peu près 35 % voilà